[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
édition du Grand JT des territoires
permettez-moi de vous souhaiter tout
d'abord une excellente nouvelle année à
tous et pour bien la débuter et bien
voici tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité avec tout d'abord le coup de
froid sur les terrasses des restaurants
privés de chauffage depuis le 1er avril
dernier une mesure pour la protection de
l'environnement qui divise les
professionnels et consommateurs
reportages de Wéo TV la chaîne de la
Voix du Nord et du Courrier Picard dans
quelques instants dans ce journal
lui n'affroy ni aux yeux ni au corps
allemand Michon est un explorateur
spécialiste du Pôle Nord la rédaction de
Canal 32 la rencontre avant sa prochaine
mission un voyage de six mois confiné
sous la banquise polaire et puis enfin
l'édition la rédaction de d'elle même TV
Sarthe nous acheminera dans les
coulisses du musée au train un atelier
gare ou des passionnés s'appellent à
prendre soin de notre patrimoine
ferroviaire
voilà maison débute donc cette première
édition de l'année avec la fraîcheur sur
les terrasses depuis 9 mois désormais
les cafetiers et restaurateurs ont
interdiction de chauffer leurs espaces
extérieurs conséquences les clients se
font plus rares et le chiffre d'affaires
s'en trouve impacté en cette période
hivernale la mesure doit permettre
d'économiser les émissions moyennes de
300 000 véhicules par an au portage de
Jérémie Houbron dans les Hauts-de-France
pour oui au TV la chaîne de la Voix du
Nord et du Courrier Picard
premier hiver sans chauffage pour les
terrasses ouvertes depuis le 1er avril
plus question pour les restaurateurs et
cafetiers de mettre en route les
parasols électriques voilà qui jettent
un coup de froid c'est vrai que si je
fumais pas je le prendrai pas dehors le
café ça c'est sûr franchement je
sélectionne plus ceux qui proposent
quand même quelque chose un chauffage
d'appoint on va dire plus traditionnel
couvertures ou soufflerie des clients
qui réfléchissent à deux fois avant de
s'installer en terrasse et des chaises
pour Anthony c'est une partie du chiffre
d'affaires qui s'envole et la
distribution de couverture pour se
chauffer ni change rien on a 90 places
intérieures 90 places extérieures
aujourd'hui je vais remplir 100% de ma
salle intérieure que je vais renouveler
plusieurs fois contre 20% à l'extérieur
selon le gouvernement l'interdiction de
chauffer ou de climatiser les terrasses
extérieures devraient chaque année
réduire de 300000 tonnes les émissions
de CO2 soit autant d'aller-retours Paris
New York en avion une mesure pleine de
bon sens pour les restaurateurs mais aux
conséquences économiques indiscutables
remettre un petit peu de la rationalité
dans les dépenses énergétiques on n'a
pas le choix bien sûr et en même temps
il faut avoir une démarche écologique
mais en même temps il faut vraiment
entendre que ils se sont des mètres
carrés quand même alors je voilà des
mètres carrés qui sont plus ou moins
utilisés et ce sont des mètres carrés
qu'on loue si on est bien sur le domaine
public si la mesure n'est pas forcément
bien reçue en sortie de crise sanitaire
peut-être permettra-t-elle au moins aux
restaurateurs de réduire la facture
d'énergie
il serait plus de 500 chaque année 500
agriculteurs qui passeraient à l'acte et
se donnerait la mort un chiffre glaçant
qui révèle le malaise au sein de cette
profession entre difficultés financières
activités compliquées et problèmes
familiaux les causes du désarroi peuvent
être variées et c'est pour lutter contre
ce fléau que des comités de pilotage
viennent d'être créés dans le Gard
objectif coordonner l'action des acteurs
sur le terrain et éviter ainsi le pire
explication de Laurie chamerla pour via
Occitanie regardez
36 agriculteurs se suicident chaque
année en Occitanie en moyenne heftovée
arboricultrissent dans l'Hérault a
failli commettre l'irréparable un burn
out et dépression politiques sur son
exploitation la pousse à bout en janvier
2021 j'ai explosé en fait je voyais plus
déçu
je voulais en finir avec tout
et j'ai été hospitalisée face à ce
constat l'État et la mutuelle de santé
agricoles lancent des comités de
pilotage départementaux pour lutter
contre le mal-être dans ce milieu un
mal-être dont les cosses sont multiples
des aléas climatiques au surendettement
en passant par des problèmes familiaux
la réponse doit être adaptée au plus
juste ça existait avant ce qui change
aujourd'hui c'est de mieux les organiser
autour d'une personne autour d'une
situation c'est à dire comment est-ce
qu'on mobilise selon la situation de la
personne ça peut être un besoin d'écoute
ça peut être un besoin d'une aide
familiale et pour mieux repérer les cas
la MSA forme des sentinelles c'est à
dire des personnes proche du milieu
agricole capable de détecter les
premiers signes de souffrance avec un
objectif de 50 cm par département
voilà et le monde agricole qui peut être
aussi d'une précieuse aide pour les
hommes exemple près de Grenoble ou une
association propose à des adultes
atteints d'autisme de s'occuper
bénévolement de certaines tâches de la
ferme nourrir les lapins nettoyer les
espaces ou encore ramasser les œufs des
activités au temps pratique que
thérapeutiques à sujet de jade Lanier
pour télégronome regarder
c'est un refrain presque quotidien qui
rythme les journées de Léo atteint
d'autisme il vient 4 jours par semaine
dans cette ferme pour s'occuper des
animaux et aujourd'hui l'heure est au
nourrissage et au nettoyage des cages à
lapin il y a le numéro des cages à faire
tel jour telle date et le numéro des
abreuvoirs à nettoyer j'ai mis du foin
dans toutes les cages 41
c'est agréable les animaux c'est calme
gentils et tout et apaisants Antonin lui
vient dans ses ateliers d'élevage depuis
presque trois ans sa mission ce jour-là
nourrir 380 poules pondeuses et ramasser
quelques œufs quand on arrive le matin
on a des quantités précises de
d'aliments à donner donc par exemple
pour ce poulailler il faut qu'on il faut
qu'on donne un sol et demi en fin de
matinée vers 11h on revient pour
ramasser des œufs 9 personnes
bénéficient de cet accompagnement par le
travail des activités qui sont une
véritable thérapie pour ses adultes
atteints d'autisme plus ou moins élevé
avoir une satisfaction d'apporter du
soin aux animaux
et puis avoir une valorisation dans le
travail effectué au sein de leur journée
et puis de voir aussi leur compétences
ou voir les personnes aussi qui prennent
un peu plus d'autonomie chaque jour
depuis 2020 faire l'avenir du berkaï
accueille et met à disposition
gratuitement ces animaux pour
l'association le bercail paysan un
échange avantageux pour les deux parties
selon cet agriculteurs ils ont pas
d'objectif c'est à dire que moi je les
oblige pas tous les tâches qu'ils
réalisent s'ils ne le font pas pour
diverses raisons par exemple s'il fait
très froid ou qu'il pleut et moi je fais
en sorte de pouvoir moi-même le faire je
leur facture pas de loyer etc en
revanche j'estime que j'ai j'ai une
heure par jour de gagner via leur
activité en France il y aurait environ
700 000 personnes atteintes d'un trouble
du spectre autistique dont 100 000 ayant
moins de 20 ans
et si pour la nouvelle année vous
décidiez de réparer au lieu d'acheter la
tendance liée à l'économie circulaire ne
cesse de se développer en France en
Moselle une entreprise spécialisée dans
la réparation d'électroménager à
domicile forment des éco-techniciens
réduire le tout jetable pour favoriser
le reconditionner c'est l'objectif un
reportage d'urani toxique et de Jean-Mi
long pour Moselle TV regardez
et là par exemple on peut voir que la
porte
la porte nécessite quelques vies
supplémentaires il scrute chaque détail
note précieusement les pièces à changer
en quelques minutes nos échos
techniciens savent si l'appareil qu'ils
ont entre les mains pourra obtenir une
seconde vie dans cet atelier très
académicien apprennent les bases du
métier on va leur faire une formation
qui va durer six mois avec une grosse
une grosse partie théorique qui qui va
servir à apprendre tous les appareils le
fonctionnement des appareils entrecoupés
de période où ils vont aller avec les
techniciens sur la route créé en 2018 à
Paris Murphy s'est implanté ensuite à
Metz en 2020 et à l'origine il
s'agissait uniquement de réparation à
domicile depuis quelques jours
l'activité est s'agrandit avec un
atelier de reconditionnement local ou
300 appareils attend déjà un coup de
neuf lave-linge réfrigérateur four tout
y passe pour réduire les déchets dans
l'électroménager Murphy propose un
forfait de 90 euros comprenant le
déplacement du technicien la main
d'oeuvre sur place et le devis 70% des
appareils seront réparés au premier
passage chez le client dans le cas
contraire un avoir sur le site est
proposé pour acheter un autre appareil
lui aussi reconditionné sur ce
sèche-linge on a changé le tampon et
puis bah il y a plus qu'à essayer voilà
depuis 2020 3500 appareils ont repris
vie entre messes Nancy et Strasbourg
elle ne répare pas de grosses machines
mais des parapluies aussi étonnant que
cela puisse paraître une bretonne on a
fait son activité près de Rennes claire
Nissan propose ainsi aux particuliers de
données une seconde vie alors par la
pluie un travail technique et historique
comme a pu le constater Raphaël tondrio
Gautier pour la chaîne thé vert regardez
alors là il faut que je répare la
baleine à l'aiguillette
voilà c'est avec un manche
dans le bois d'un seul tenant un
parapluie long c'est vraiment les plus
joli loin d'être superstitieuse claire
lisant donne une seconde vie à ses
parapluies à 41 ans cette ancienne
podologue est devenue réparatrice après
une rencontre en Corrèze utilisée le
réemploi tout tout ça ça me parlait bien
et
puis j'ai vu connaissance de ce métier
parce que j'ai eu moi-même un parapluie
de cassé et donc j'ai pris contact avec
Madame debat qui est installé en Corrèze
qui et puis elle m'a formée dans pour ce
nouveau métier claire s'est installé à
son compte en juillet dernier et depuis
elle enregistre 250 réparations à son
actif des gestes plutôt simples en
apparence mais qui demande de la
précision c'est pas des gestes hyper
technique
c'est vraiment faut trouver la bonne
pièce il faut être ingénieux parce qu'il
y a des fois des pièces qu'on a pas donc
il de les fabriquer et pour un objet
comme celui-ci il faut compter une
demi-heure de réparation des baleines au
ressort chaque partie peut être changer
compter entre 20 et 30 euros un objet
qui touche un bouton que tout le monde
utilise en fait on peut tous utiliser
qu'on soit enfant qu'on soit plus âgé
voilà c'est un objet qui protège un
objet aussi qui est beau qui peut être
un accessoire de mode ça y est donc
voilà il est reparti
et voilà il est comme neuf
l'esprit des fêtes est-il encore là en
ce début de mois de janvier les
chrétiens fêtent l'épiphanie l'occasion
de découvrir encore le travail
exceptionnel de Jean-Claude de Carsalade
un créateur de crèche cette octogénaire
conçoit et expose chaque année une
crèche dite napolitaine dans une église
de Toulouse un travail minutieux comme
vous le voyez sur ces images de nos
confrères de la Dépêche du Midi où ce
que toi près de 80 personnages
miniatures écoutez à ce propos se
passionner au micro de Manon nocci
regardez
les choses importantes de la crèche
napolitaine c'est d'abord l'auberge les
marchands de tissus
africains plus haut les pêcheurs les
crèches a été depuis ma plus tendre
enfance tout ça c'est fermé dans une
armoire toute restant de l'année donc en
ce moment je la prête à la dalleba de
parce que je suis très attaché à la
Dalbade chaque jour on peut ajouter
quelque chose il manque beaucoup de
personnes vous voyez là aussi vous voyez
une auberge elles sont pas assez
nombreuses il en faudrait une vingtaine
de personnes
[Musique]
voilà et sachez que ce travail
fantastique est à voir jusqu'au 2
février dans l'église de la Dalbade à
Toulouse
voilà c'est en transition après les
repas plutôt chargés et quelques soirées
éventuellement arrosées c'est l'heure
peut-être pour vous de reprendre une
activité sportive à ce propos
connaissez-vous le film ping tonic cette
pratique est un mélange comme son nom
l'indique de ping pong de fitness
à séduire à nouveau public en France 80%
des joueurs de tennis de table sont des
hommes alors pour inverser la tendance
le film ping tonic promet plaisir et
fort reportage dans l'unique club du
Val-d'Oise en Île-de-France des Lisa
Zanetta pour via 95
vous allez vous mettre en appui sur les
avant-bras sur la table j'ai entendu
derrière pied Flex allier fitness et
tennis de table c'est la promesse du fit
pintonic objectif
développer le tonus musculaire
l'habileté ou encore les réflexes
ça fait mal car ce soir-là ce sont les
bras et le fessier qu'elody et les
adhérents de travail au programme de la
séance agilité pongiste la balle doit
passer au-dessus et en dessous de la
barre allez à quoi en dessous aussi les
filles pas que au dessus là sinon c'est
trop facile et pour ça les joueuses
doivent rentrer le ventre et serrer le
postérieur il y a toujours un lien entre
le thème de la séance en fitness et les
exercices de tennis de table quand on
fait les bras on peut faire des smatchs
même si cette salle peut faire poncer le
contraire moins d'un genre de ping-pong
sur 6 est une femme les femmes n'aiment
pas le tennis de table
c'est simple et c'est pour ça qu'elle a
fait des ration pour pouvoir féminiser
les clubs de tennis de table ils ont
créé le fiting pour faire venir les
femmes au tennis de table d'une façon
ludique officiellement reconnue en 2012
le fit pink Tony qui est un pari réussi
pour la Fédération de tennis de table
sur 700 adhérents 90% sont des femmes
comme Christelle et Elena fidèle à leur
activité favorite depuis trois ans ça va
c'est original et en fait moi je trouve
que c'est moins répétitif que le tennis
de table parce que en fait on fait
d'autres mouvements et ça nous permet
aussi de voir autre chose à côté avec
cette unique section de fit ping Tony du
Val d'Oise le club de Saint-Leu-la-Forêt
fait partie des 69 autres en France à
développer cette activité et voilà merci
les filles
voilà du sport lui en fait tous les
jours ou presque Alban Michaud et ce que
l'on appelle un explorateur ce
spécialiste des missions dans le pôle
Nord se prépare à une nouvelle
expédition vivre sous la banquise
pendant 6 mois un sujet étonnant au
ramifications scientifique et
environnementale rencontre sur sa terre
natale de l'aube avec la rédaction de
Canal 32
album Michon n'a pas froid aux yeux du
haut de ses 45 ans l'explorateur polaire
se rend dans les milieux les plus froids
et au styles de la planète en métier
d'explorateur c'est vrai que quand on
dit ça ça n'existe plus métier c'est et
ben en fait si si on veut protéger le
monde il faut en comprendre son
évolution et comprendre son évolution il
y a les scientifiques il y a les
scientifiques de laboratoire les
scientifiques de terrain et
l'explorateur c'est la presse
scientifique de terrain Troyens
d'origine tout a commencé ici dans
l'Aube j'ai commencé à la piscine des
Chartreux à l'âge de 10-11 ans parce que
à force de dire à mes parents je vais
faire de la plongée je veux faire la
plongée et mon on est faire un baptême
de plongée au sud à 3 à l'époque ma
première plongée sous la glace c'est à
Clairet au terroove j'ai sous glace de
nuit je suis ressortie j'étais gelé mais
j'ai trouvé ça magnifique
sa première expédition plongée en équipe
sous le pôle Nord géographique sa
dernière aventure 62 jours pour
traverser le passage du Nord-Ouest en
solitaire mais la plus compliquée
jusqu'ici son exp en kayak des mers à
deux sur la côte Est du Groenland depuis
2015 il vit de ses explorations
objectifs fournir des données régulières
aux scientifiques d'après Alban tout est
imaginable ce qu'il a amené à mettre en
place son prochain projet qui s'appelle
la mission biodisus l'Odyssée des
biocéanotes biocéanot c'est des gens qui
vont vivre sous l'eau donc je vais
construire une base de recherche
sous-marine où on va être à 4 à
l'intérieur c'est une base de recherche
qui va faire 24 mètres de long 2 mètres
30 de large et on va vivre 6 mois sous
la banquise arctique ou il y aura des
programmes scientifiques physiologiques
également et puis la deuxième chose
c'est puisqu'on est dans les endroits
extrêmes de la planète et bien il va
falloir tester les prototypes les
prototypes qui feront le monde de demain
toute une partie de son travail consiste
à partager le fruit de ses expériences
d'où la publication de son livre l'école
des explorateurs dans lequel il donne
des conseils pour préparer sa propre
aventure
voilà et après six mois passés sous la
banquise polaire Alban Michaud aura bien
le droit à quelques jours de vacances
une transition parfaite pour découvrir à
présent le tout nouveau village du Club
Med inauguré à Tignes un établissement
qui ne manque pas de superlatif hors
norme prestigieux ou encore démesuré le
site a nécessité un investissement de
près de 130 millions d'euros
présentation des lieux à plus de 2000
mètres d'altitude d'Emmanuel JO pour la
rédaction de 8 Mont-Blanc
au pied des pistes du Val Claret la
structure a de quoi impressionné sur
plus de 40 000 m², le tout nouveau
centre du Club Med se prépare à
accueillir près d'un millier de
touristes dès les prochains jours un
chantier de longue date et qui vient
donc remplacer l'ancienne structure du
club implantée depuis 1958 dans la
station savoyarde un nouveau Resort qui
évolue avec son temps et surtout en
fonction de la demande de la clientèle
les visiteurs au Club Med font du ski
mais vont profiter de d'un spa vont
profiter d'une piscine ou aller faire
des cours de sport il y a une trentaine
d'années serait semblé complètement
absurde d'avoir dans un hôtel de
montagne des salles de sport des clients
qui eux aussi ont bien changé bien loin
des Français de la classe moyenne le
club attire aujourd'hui des membres
venus des quatre coins du globe avec une
forte croissance du public sud-américain
ces dernières années à date jusqu'à fin
janvier nous sommes à 80% de remplissage
donc surtout le mois de janvier 75% de
remplissage via le Brésil les forces
majeures c'est le Brésil l'Israël et
après l'Europe ou alors on commence à
recevoir des personnes de l'Afrique du
Sud qui viennent découvrir justement le
ski à la montagne et pour accueillir au
mieux tous ces ressortissants étrangers
390 employés sont nécessaires une main
d'oeuvre elle aussi issue de toutes les
nationalités présentes sur le site et
complété par près de 80 moniteurs ESF
qui seront exclusivement dédiés au
fameux GM d'ailleurs un site comme
celui-ci va forcément impacter le modèle
même de la station si on estime à 12
millions d'euros les retombées
économiques de la présence du Club Med
sur le village de Tignes le resort c'est
implanté sur l'ancien parking à ciel
ouvert du front de neige autant de place
de stationnement qui ne seront pas tout
de suite remplacées
environnemental aussi souterrain au nord
du Val Claret au sommet du Val Claret va
voir le jour d'ici 2025 et qui permettra
aussi d'améliorer la qualité de
l'expérience client dotée d'une centrale
de chauffage nouvelle génération et de
nombreux panneaux solaires se résorbent
se veut être exemplaire un engagement
environnemental qui s'inscrit également
dans le plan de rénovation énergétique
de la station avant de prochaine
réhabilitation au cœur même du Val
Claret
il est le seul avec l'Opéra national de
Paris a possédé en son sein des ateliers
de construction l'opéra de Saint-Etienne
se dévoile en ce début d'année aux
caméras de TL7 dans la Loire dans les
coulisses vous allez le voir c'est tout
un monde qui s'organise pour la bonne
réalisation des œuvres visite guidée
entre décor et costumes de Céline
arcilia regardez ce reportage
vous reconnaissez sûrement ces fauteuils
Bordeaux et sa grande scène mais l'opéra
de Saint-Étienne garde bien caché
d'autres trésors derrière la salle
quelques mains s'affaires nous sommes
dans l'atelier menuiserie c'est ici que
sont élaborés et fabriqués les décors
rigides des œuvres qui seront bientôt
jouées aujourd'hui ce sont ceux de la
Veuve Joyeuse le travail est minutieux
pour permettre au spectacle d’être le
plus grandiose possible ici il n'y a pas
de routine
de travailler auprès de personnes
créatives comme des scénographes des
metteur anciennes et d'ajuster selon les
contraintes techniques que les projets
soient sans cesse renouvelés c'est
quelque chose qui est dynamisant c'est à
dire qu'on n'est pas amené à faire tout
le temps la même chose juste à côté on
travaille le métal un peu plus loin les
décors sont peints avant d'arriver enfin
sur scène pour le montage dans quelques
jours les artistes seront là pour les
répétitions leur costumes seront prêts
et réalisés par d'autres artistes comme
SIRPA certaines pièces comme ce manteau
représente des semaines de travail et si
qui est important il faut aussi broder
avec certaines contraintes techniques
des robes qui a une traîne ou le manteau
qui est qui est très qui est lourde en
fait tout simplement donc c'est bien
réfléchi très précis avoir ses ateliers
au cœur même de l'opéra est une
particularité stéphanoise c'est unique
en province un atout pour gérer les
coûts pas plus de 70 000 euros pour la
partie décor et costumes et cela permet
de proposer des oeuvres made in loires
alors c'est une très grosse force parce
que ça permet à l'Opéra de Saint-Étienne
de produire ces ouvrages lyriques on en
produit en moyenne la moitié voire un
peu plus chaque saison à Saint-Étienne
on peut donc voir des interprétations
d’œuvres uniques des œuvres qui
s'exportent ensuite et participent à la
renommée de Saint-Étienne l'opéra de
Saint-Étienne fait partie des grands
opéras français on a des coproducteurs
qui sont des coproducteurs de renom le
Théâtre des Champs-Élysées le Palazzo
brutzané sont des maisons évidemment de
très haut niveau et l'opéra de
Saint-Étienne fait de ces grandes
maisons un succès évidemment aussi local
la salle enregistre plus de 90% de
fréquentation à chaque représentation
allez prenons maintenant la direction de
la Sarthe dans ce journal ou des
passionnés du monde ferroviaire
entretiennent tout un pan de notre
patrimoine au musée Hautrage les
bénévoles ne comptent pas leurs heures
pour choyer notamment une locomotive
vieille de plus d'un siècle rencontre
dans leur atelier gare avec Enzo Maubert
journaliste pour LM TV Sarthe
chaque semaine c'est le même concert des
marteaux et de meuleuse
au musée au train de semur-en-vallons
ils sont une dizaine outils à la main à
remettre en état améliorer nettoyer tout
un patrimoine ferroviaire
tout corps d'état comme on dirait bah il
y a de la voix entretenir il y a de la
peinture à faire il y a de l'électricité
il y a de la maîtrise des végétaux il y
a de la soudure il y a de la mécanique
enfin bref tous les métiers possibles
ici la reine c'est la locomotive de
Coville un fleuron français du début du
20e siècle à la haute saison elle fera
le plein de voyageurs et malgré son âge
Denis c'est toujours comment lui
redonner un petit coup de neuf donc là
je suis en train d'installer un système
de lubrification en fin de compte de la
voix c'est-à-dire qu'on va arroser la
voix avec de l'eau tout simplement ce
qui va permettre de limiter le bruit au
musée au train il y a là maintenant se
met aussi parfois des projets un peu
ambitieux fou diront certains Gaston
c'est par exemple lancé dans la
construction d'une véritable locomotive
à air comprimé ça c'est une machine
on va monter un compresseur sur un temps
d'air derrière
moi
je devrais le faire il faudra encore
attendre un peu avant de voir le rêve de
Gaston se réaliser pour l'aider à vie
aux amateurs le musée recherche des
bénévoles soudeur ou métallier
voilà une autre passion encore pour
terminer ce journal c'est les deux de
Delphine obrit elle est colorée et elle
est faite en papier mâché et toute
tournée vers de drôles de bestioles cet
artiste plasticienne vient d'ouvrir une
boutique consacrée à son univers
étonnant et à son bestiaire haut en
couleur sujet de Marie Daniel rogovitz
et de Anne Didier pour vos jeux
Télévisions
les bestioles de Delphine Aubry sont
partout du solo plafond dans une
boutique ouverte spécialement et forme
d’investir ou en couleur avec ce drôle
de regard ça c'est ma signature et
regarde un petit peu le monde qui les
entoure d'une façon interrogative et
puis bon je les aime bien des fois un
petit peu un petit peu simple et un
petit peu ni ou des fois en colère ou
des fois interrogateurs ou triste même
c'est la patte de l'artiste sortie des
Beaux-Arts d'Épinal mais autodidacte
dans cette technique de la sculpture en
papier mâché en plus de 20 ans de
création elle ne les compte plus des
milliers de bestioles dans son atelier
Delphine Aubry ne cesse de créer en mars
elle renouera avec ses premières amours
les poulettes une petite poulette comme
je suis en train de faire c'est à peu
près deux à trois heures de travail tout
étape confondu puis une grosse grosse
bête comme le chien qu'on a à côté là
c'est entre 30 et mais dans cette arche
de Noé delphine a toujours conservé son
premier spécimen une célèbre
Henriette Dumont et son nom c'était
l'exposition bikini avec des cochonnes
en maillot de bain et elle elle a un
petit peu toute nue parce que ses coups
de soleil se mit intégrale quant à la
boutique où l'on retrouve ses ouvrages
quelle sera un lieu d'exposition
permanente vos vaches cochons et temps
de couvées les bestioles ont fait le
tour de l'évolution des espèces animales
et elles ont désormais pignons sur rue
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition du
Grand JT des territoires merci de nous
avoir suivis on se retrouve très vite
pour une prochaine édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]